what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime podcast
called rant cafe this is number 32 and
for this episode I thought that we would
talk about the prospect of attack on
Titan season 3 we got the huge news
about a week and a half ago then attack
mankind season 3 is actually going to be
coming in 2018 which I think surprised a
lot of us because while I was saying and
thinking that one to two years is
reasonable we were all afraid it was
gonna be another four years again until
the next season
however thankfully we are going to be
getting a third season in 2018 hopefully
of course some people think it's gonna
be delayed so that's what we're gonna be
talking about in this stream what to
expect from third season is it actually
going to happen or do you think it's
gonna be delayed again all that kind of
stuff and joining me today we have anime
recon we have Jojo talks too much
who was requested by multiple people to
come back on Ren cafe including I
believe snootily requested him oh and
and of course cyanide blizzard is back
with us a kay table kun what's up guys
how you all doing I am kind of flattered
right now I'm like people ask for me
that's so nice we're like why wouldn't
they ask for you ah that's or nah I am
flattered so I had to sip tea very
important oh yeah I'm drinking coffee
over here this is rent cafe bro not only
eat the rant tea house amen
they serve they serve tea at cafes too
you know I mean not not like not like
regular tea they serve like specialty
teas but it's all good I guess man I
guess actually I only I my coffee I have
to cut off at like 10 o'clock cuz I like
otherwise I'll drink like six pots a day
I'm kind of a kind of addictive okay I
see so it's a problem for you well yeah
welcome back Jojo glad to have you and
I'm a big fan of attack on Titan anime
he did live reactions to all the
episodes are you doing bro
let's go type these three chat i'm hype
for it man
I'm so excited for it to be in 2018 if
it gets delayed which hopefully it
doesn't I'm gonna get so pissed
what will we do if it gets too late
again guys let me know in the chat are
we gonna protest are we gonna chain
ourselves to the anime studio front gate
what are we gonna do because that would
really really be terrible if they're
like yeah you're getting it in 2018
everyone's like yes thank you and then
they're like oh we gotta postpone him
again oh you know he think I know what
we should do attack on time is made by
wood studio correct yes so here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna get a ticket to
Japan fly over there with a helicopter
fly a machine gun knock knock
[ __ ] kick there kick the door
down and just spray and praise because
they haven't released it okay okay
recon let me stop you right there let's
not red threatened with violence and
it's gonna sound like I hope these
actions real salty on Twitter for a
couple days and then maybe get over it
later but now be really go salty
let's not threaten people to go Arnold
Schwarzenegger helicopter studio however
of course you don't be super pissed I
know if they don't need it again like I
said in like some videos that I made on
this subject they have all the money and
hype in the world for attack on Titan
it's like the biggest anime out there
especially outside of Japan it's so huge
they so they have all the funding they
have the audience they have the manga
the original source material there's
plenty to go we're only like halfway
through the manga at the end of the
second season but there's so much more
to go so there's no reason why they
would not you know release the season in
a reasonable time matter you know you
can't do it in two months obviously a
anime season does take a long time to
make the animation is high-quality for
attack on Titan which we all appreciate
but a year to two years absolutely
reasonable time period so I really hope
that they do get that done
cyanide blizzard what do you think you
are an expert on anime you've followed
you know development cycles of anime you
follow anime releases you do your first
impression series on your channel let us
know what you think
well it's a really interesting matter
you could brought it up to me before is
a question and it's kind of one of the
things that's really made me curious
cuz the thing is with the way studio
wits handled a lot of this has been very
interesting and normally off of the
heels of a season that was as hot as the
first season attack on tightening that
was huge and it's not normal for a
company to wait that long but at the
same time it also kind of makes sense as
well you don't want to be a one-trick
pony you don't want that to be your only
thing which was nice that they did a
coven re as well so they were kind of
expanding outward but that's the same
thing though is they spent a long time
waiting before they did a second season
or even confirmed it so that's when it
came to a third season it was really
hard to say generally most shows when
they switched over from 24 to 26
episodes to 12 episodes it was to ease
up on production so that they could do
something like wait a year and then
produce another season then that's a
more common thing that we see but the
thing with wit is we couldn't really
predict that because they haven't
necessarily functioned in the same way
so when they did announce that I was
actually kind of surprised even despite
the fact that it was sort of a common
thing because that's just it you know we
don't know so if there is something like
a delay I guess it would be kind of
expected but it's really nice to see I'm
sure that this reduce reduce meant of
episodes has been a lot easier for them
and of course in several years have
passed while hype is still there a lot
of that initial momentum kind of
subsides a little bit so you definitely
want to keep that ball rolling you want
to keep it going and I think that's
gonna be really great so if they are
able to do a third season in 2018 I
think that's gonna be fantastic I think
it's gonna be really beneficial for them
the fanbase is gonna benefit everyone
will benefit so even if it's two years I
still think that's gonna be great but
they definitely want to keep that
momentum going
obviously there's enough source material
for them to work off of so they should
be more than sufficient but yeah
definitely it's definitely gonna be
great but yeah it's really interesting
how its handle it a lot different than
other studios yeah yeah and however
that's that's what makes it interesting
I guess right the whole the whole
craziness or surrounding attack on Titan
such a huge
be such a all these delays things like
that it's like ah but it is interesting
it's interesting we're sure chad is
going on with the hook I can't even you
know keep up with it at some points a
few people asked do we think that the
season 3 will have 12 or 25 episodes
24 uh we obviously have no idea I would
be okay with it being 12 if it comes out
in 2018 so if they're having
unreasonable
you know production time I'm okay with
12 I thought the 12 of season 2 were
really good
there was no like slow moments it was
really fast paced we learned a lot there
was a lot of character development I
personally loved that style I know in
near the middle of the first season
there was some dragging some pacing
issues where a second season was just
insane and I know a lot of people are
saying that they like the second season
more so I would be okay with a third
season that is twelve episodes like that
but you know as long as we get that
there's I would not mind of course a
longer season either that will be
totally cool so you know as long as we
get it in a reasonable time 2018 either
way I would be really happy yeah I I
definitely agree I remember um when my
hair accademia came out its first season
I think was 13 episodes or something
like that and you could tell that that
was some testing the waters like will
this show like survive and then it did
and so bones was like cool give them 25
next season
so my think I think that the reason it
was 13 was maybe Witt was like we might
have waited too long like what if what
if all the hype is dead and we waste all
the money on 25 episodes and they only
really care for the first like ten so I
think maybe they were testing waters and
next season they'll they'll bust up 25
I'm hoping I don't know I want I want
like a big long season but who knows
yeah sure I mean I would be super happy
with that as long as of course they
don't cut corners and they produce it
really well because we want to make sure
that it's produced really well by the
way we had um where is he
am plays he says he loves the channel
here and he was like I wish you could be
uploading attack on Titan videos every
second I wish man but they take a lot of
work as you know so
we are working on another big project
for attack on Titan soon and another big
project for another anime soon that I
hope is gonna be dropping tomorrow or
the next day so stay tuned for that
right here on the channel well yeah in
terms of this whole season three thing
I'm very excited I know how some people
are asking the chat if you can talk
manga obviously I've read the manga and
my brother has read the manga multiple
times however there are some anime only
fans in here so try to keep the spoilers
to a minimum if you can you know I'm not
personally gonna get mad but maybe
someone like recon who I believe is
anime only will get mad but one thing
that we can expect from season 3 I will
say without revealing too much spoiler
the too many spoilers we are gonna learn
a lot more about the world let's talk on
Titan a lot of Secrets are going to be
revealed there's gonna be a lot of
political intrigue factions things like
that happening a lot more Levi's for all
the Levi's fans so yeah I can't honestly
I can't wait for season 3 I love season
2 more even than the first one
season 3 should be great and of course
here on the channel we will keep you
posted with all the news as soon as we
get it the same day you will get it as
well but yeah recon as in anime only
what do you you know what are you hoping
to see in the third season first of all
before I talk about that I just want to
talk about spoilers now when I did my
final reaction to attack on Titan I got
a lot of views I was really happy but
during that time I was also getting
comments loads and loads of comments
were mostly about spoilers because in
the final episode we got a mysterious
character who was riding the beast Titan
I had an idea he was probably the beast
Titan or he was he probably controls a
Titan a lot of people spoiled so yeah I
tried not to read them but there were so
many of them yeah it's somebody
impossible it's impossible
boilers so that's why I would recommend
just reading the manga because it's like
almost impossible not to get spoilers
especially if you're you have a channel
where you're actually making videos
regarding it you're always gonna you're
just gonna you're gonna get spoiled so
either don't care about spoilers like
old anime like he breaks he tells me
you know I don't even care about
spoilers i watch your guys videos you
can read the manga yet and I enjoy it or
you know just read the manga if you
don't want to get spoiled because you
are guy recurring reaction videos man if
you haven't seen the show you don't know
what's gonna be shown so there's only so
much you can do to try and prevent
against that because my name is Jojo I
get support everyone it just assumes
like he's clearly read the JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure manga oh cool I know
all the things but I guess yeah is that
you're actually like named Raj or just a
nickname it is my real name is like
Joseph but I thought Joey was cooler cuz
friends was coming out as I was growing
up so I want it to be Joey instead and
my parents called me Jojo and then
eventually it just became Jojo and I was
like cool I'll make that my youtube name
since somebody else took Joey anime man
parents and I meant how dare they name
him they should have known years later
but yeah you being Jojo on having an
anime channel it's like man this guy's
must be really into JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure like guys yeah crazy exactly
yeah for sure
I don't you told me what I was expecting
for the next season well I'm pretty much
expecting the continuation of the story
for the beast' time because we don't
know much about him yet and we don't
know who the last who that who that
mysterious character was so we're pretty
much gonna know about his story and who
he is and how he became the beast hidin
that's probably what we're gonna learn
but you might already know what's gonna
happen
Anna man cuz he you read them on but I
know what's gonna happen but that manga
is ongoing right so there's still many
things that we don't know even if you've
read the manga which is cool because of
course you can then make theories and
chat about it and stuff like that so
that is a really cool thing yeah
and we're also gonna of course learn
more about Aaron's new ability to
control time is he's gonna use it a lot
more so I can't wait to see that
honestly can't wait yeah I think and
figure to figure out how to use it right
because that's the thing he has no idea
how
use it yeah that's a big thing in attack
on Titan like the I was struck by both
in the manga and the anime how attack on
Titan how long they take to reveal
really important things about the world
like how long it actually takes and it
still works
you know the anime is still interesting
it's still so much tension so much drama
and entertaining cuz you would think
that you know if they were teasing you
for this long and you don't know what's
happening you'd be like man screw this
I'm giving up and yet they managed to do
it so well agreed
I have tried I remember like in the
in-between between season 1 and 2 in the
time where we all thought like it's just
never gonna happen
apparently wit Studios hates money and
they're not gonna make season 2 and I I
just gave up and I remember to ask my
friend like what happens because like
they were reading the manga so I Chi I
know a great deal of things but there
are still some things that I didn't know
so I was just like I'll just watch the
the video anime uproar uploaded on
what's what's coming next in the world
of attack on Titan so now I know all the
things Thank You Jo don't think yeah of
course yeah those videos we don't make
them so the people don't have to read
the manga we make them to encourage
people to read the manga because of how
interesting it all is and of course some
people who are read the manga a while
ago we put everything in one place right
cuz it's all spread out throughout the
manga so we're like okay you want to
know everything about you know Aaron or
you want to know everything about the
beasts Titan here it all is in one place
instead of having to reread the whole
manga to learn all of it right which is
a huge pain yeah especially with the
series like attack on Titan with how big
it is and there's so much that's going
on as well it's great to have BAM
nice video there catches you up you know
about 20 minutes of your time give or
take there boom all caught up on that
yeah that's the hope and that's the plan
shut up imperialist opinions I see him
often and sin of code is in there well
and a lot of other people
Philly Superman I recognize some
lightning in darkness tsukushi cause it
welcome everyone to Rand cafe a weekly
podcast though here
here on this channel talking about all
sorts of anime stuff every Thursday 5:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time today talking
about attack on Titan season 3 what to
expect what we're excited for and so on
cyanide tell me something you want to
see and see that you and you are known
as a critic especially on first episodes
so I would love to hear what you hope to
see you know in terms of second season
what you thought what you hope to see in
the third season what you hope to see in
the first episode and if you don't want
to reveal too much of the story you can
say what you want to see in terms of
animation or production or whatever you
like well the big thing the nicest thing
is that doing shorter seasons allows for
more production costs to go into
animation so forth allows that the
budget to be spread out as opposed to
being spread thin which it is for longer
seasons obviously of course with the
money they rank in for this it allows
them to put more money towards it as
well but I think the second season had a
really nice start to it I thought they
did a great job of recapturing that
interest intrigue the part that made it
really enjoyable to watch attack on
Titan immersed you back in what made it
so addictive in the first place
and I don't know if they necessarily
need to go that far out but I certainly
don't think it'd be a bad thing they're
really good at creating momentum
intrigue there as well as drawing you in
off the first episode I felt that both
seasons have done that pretty decently
well you know obviously the show is
without its own fault but in terms of
entertaining its immensely so it's very
enjoyable to watch so I'm looking
forward to the third season keeping that
and keeping that momentum going that it
has so I think that's going to be really
interesting to see how they build upon
the second season if there were certain
aspects that they felt could have been
improved upon for that or I believe let
me know it mentioned the comments about
it being maybe a 26 episode 2 - core
series so basically two different sees
two different 13 episode seasons or so
throughout the year I mean that's just
that you know it's gonna be really
interesting to see how they how they
handle that
it'll be really intriguing above all but
I think it's more than anything
it's gonna be really enjoyable because
of course obviously with the way the
second season has ended it's really
starting to pick up we're really
starting to get into it so the hype is
there now it's just a matter of how they
work with that yes absolutely and I
think that the like I said I love season
two I thought it was great drama great
hype and I definitely want them to carry
that on so we can wait a year and the
hype will continue but if we have to
wait another four years everyone will
you know forget what the hell happened
and hurt our hype by the way old anime
are you here hello hello showing up late
but showing up and that's what counts
what some room sorry about being late
guys but hello good to be here also
welcome to Eren Jaeger in the chat Wow
the Eren Jaeger Eren Jaeger is in the
chat and you know I always think Aaron
shouldn't you be out there fighting the
Titans but you know we have Armin in
here we had Aaron in here they're
welcome they're welcome they're good
guys there's 2spooky and love king oh
yeah LOM king shuddhodhan hey I saw him
earlier too spooky of course by the way
Crusader entertainment said that he
feels like the plot of season 3 will
gloss over the political stuff and
that's in the manga there is a political
arc called the uprising arc where like I
said deals with a lot of factions and
things within the walls government and
you know that kind of stuff and I
actually I don't mind that stuff I
studied political science right and to
me that's actually interesting so I know
a lot of people complain about that
something thing it's boring but to me
that's really interesting so I don't
even want them to gloss over it I really
like that type of stuff and of course
Levi are bored
Levi is crucial in this arc so you know
I don't know I'm I'm cool with I like
action but I also like you know the
political intrigue factionalism I'm a
big fan of that stuff so I want to see
that in season 3 as well I just want to
see Levi I like it was it felt like you
know like when a character in a TV show
gets cast into a movie so like they're
not in that like so for an entire season
this one characters he's there but you
see him sparingly it felt like Levi the
character
in another movie so he's like I can only
be here for a couple episodes and then
I'm gonna disappear again but I'll be
back next season I promise really honest
we don't need to see Levi I think I
think we should all agree that it's time
for our wind to shine because he was a
badass he was such a bad as these past
episodes why not both oh yeah I think I
think Levi had too much I mean from the
first season what I think it's time for
someone new to stand up I mean everyone
should agree with this yeah I get a girl
and there a new character should stand
out a lot more than Levi the stun well I
think we have to agree with George or
ponder this we didn't see enough Levi in
season 2 but you know that's the way it
goes
we will though see more Levi in season 3
I can promise you that it was all season
2 was all building up and then Eli and
Erwin show up kind of near the end but
yeah season 3 is gonna feature a lot
more of them Briggs let me know how
since you came in late what are your
impressions of season 2 and what are you
waiting for
to see in season 3 are you excited I'm
definitely excited I actually like
Steven to a lot more than season 1 in my
opinion like I was
I enjoyed season 1 but I wasn't like a
huge fan I feel like season 2 when I
clinched it for me I think it all comes
down to like the world of attack on
titan being extremely interesting and
actually the type of guy I am I like
learning about series and that's why I
mentioned before I don't even care about
spoilers I've been watching your videos
like simply gotchas videos and spooky
use videos on like attack on Titan and
I'm like it's going way in the spoiler
territory bum is learning so much most
like the world and the series and I find
it so interesting I think that's what
they did good in season 2 like we're
just learning a lot more about the
Titans on both the world and like you're
saying it's gonna go into like political
stuff with like the walls and like
politics with Incept within the walls I
think that's really cool and that's what
I hope they like go into in season 3
like it's a little they have to keep
while like I thought it's a very
mysterious world and we're always
learning more a little bit by a little
bit and I'm always like so curious to
find out more in the next episode like
the actions great to off course and I
the action and that's like half the
reason I'm there but is like the other
half of it the concept in the mystery to
the world and the tight ends absolutely
yeah and that's the thing like like I
said attack time does a great job of
kind of teasing us with the world it's
like you know there's these big
mysteries like the basement like how
long did they tease us with the basement
and all that stuff so there's all these
great mysteries and they pace it so well
and like if you read the manga for
example reading the manga that the stuff
that's covered in season one the manga
is actually much more fast paced because
season one like I said it had some
filler moments near the middle because
the manga was obviously five years
younger back then yeah but now when I
read the manga after watching season one
it's much more fast paced and of course
now four years in between the two
seasons we have a lot more manga
materials so there it is no longer an
issue that we don't have enough manga so
we have to do fillers right so that's
another really good thing and that's why
I can't wait to see season three guys
hopefully if not another four years
hopefully there's enough material that
they don't have to wait that long but
here's what I'm expecting from the third
season since since it's coming earlier
than season two did them in season two
to like four to five years to air since
we're getting the third season next year
it might be another twelve episodes most
likely will be another twelve episodes I
woods but they also had with my hero
academia they went from the first 13 or
12 to 1 year later doing a full 25
episode so it's possible like some some
might say that attack a tiny animation
takes longer and I'm not an expert but I
think it's possible to make the 25
episode and there's enough material to
make a 25 episode in terms of the manga
but again like I said I would be happy
with 12 as long as we get it in 2018 and
not in 2028 yeah I honestly I would be
extremely happy with 12 if they did it I
like a faster rate if they did 12 like
every colleague every other season or
every like up like like fall to like an
opposite to even type of thing um I'm
trying to say here is like sometimes
twelve episodes the pacing is better
less filler and it's a lot of time like
more well done in 12 episodes even
though it might be rushed but if they're
not rushing it cuz they know there's
another
you than it might be I bet it like
season 2 I prefer to wait more than
season one yeah that's the thing um blue
exorcist whether you're a fan or not the
season that they did the twelve episodes
that was really strong
I mean first season wasn't too bad but
that second season was really good and
really well done and it shined massively
so and I think that was the same thing
with attack on Titan but sorry recon you
were about to say something no no I know
I agree with you Alexes season 1 was not
too bad but the second season was was on
point like you said I I definitely agree
it was a good show as well if you if you
guys haven't watched it you need to
watch it
I thought that this season one started
off extremely strong and it finished
extremely strong but then there are some
parts in the middle that was a bit kind
of draggy but anyway I still love the
show and of course season 2 just amazing
yo Jane in the chat says I'm guessing a
sheet I can't wait to watch the uprising
are can I made it because we're gonna
see a lot more urban Levi's his story a
handi shine and I agree like I can't
wait to see the uprising arc like I said
a lot of people can play at home and too
much politics I'm like that I love it so
I can't wait to see more of that
hopefully we get a lot of it I really I
want to see more of Hans getting drunk
and John hanging out with Marcus why
would I see most of all is better Holt
get some any let me say some can we all
agree that Aaron's mother was one fine
looking man like when they had that
history like she was so beautiful
boiler alert she dies in the first
episode and first chapter but beautiful
woman damn you damn you
Krishan you lucky bastard I'm just
reading the chat saying like Greece just
mad yeah I found my phone
oh nice by the way do you guys know
where any as hell because
she we have not seen her in season two
she's underground she's held underground
I really hope we see her in the season
three key bonus I missed a plan like
like yeah this skate fly like imagine an
escape I'll make it a little bit more
interesting yeah well she would have to
be rescued because she herself cannot
escape right I'm 100% sure that Reiner
Amir and better health are gonna go
rescue her most likely yes all the kind
of left fielders well they didn't get
Aaron and they didn't get any ER or
whatever her name is first they're gonna
come back with him a knife attack or the
end of the season it wouldn't seem like
they're coming back with a knife attack
or like Beast I did another thing and
whoever that guy on his shoulder was as
a trippy ending by the way am and plays
earlier said that the more likes this
stream gets the more likely it is that a
talking Titan will come out sooner
season three converse is not I know this
is not verified but I definitely think
that the more likes we get on the stream
the sooner it's coming guys I definitely
think it's worth at ROI smash that like
button sorry boys
I also heard the more likes it gets
there will also be another season of
spice in wolf and all of them and the
next code geass will come up much faster
so maybe legend tells it called Yahoo
legend has season three sometime in the
distant future who knows yes
oh yeah speaking of the speaking of
which guys I had a few questions in a
chat asking about seven deadly sins
season two news and Tokyo ghoul season
three news nothing on Tokyo ghoul seven
deadly sins as well nothing on the
season however there is apparently a
seven deadly sins ps4 game coming out
Briggs are you informed I am NOT I
didn't even hear about that but sadly
there's no news on a season three I've
been waiting
I read the PS that a ps4 game of
suddenly sins will be coming out which
is weird because it's like if it's
popular enough to be getting a new
for a game why are we not hearing more
about season 2 like come on and there's
definitely enough material to adapt in
like another 24 episodes like easily
well it's really interesting because
code of Suba is sort of going through
the same phase they're getting a ps4 PS
Vita visual novel game that's coming out
but as of right now there's no news on a
third season that's still all up in the
air if not it may not possibly happen so
it's really interesting how it works I
don't know if they're using that to test
the waters to see the demand for that or
just sort of as an in-between but
especially for something like seven
deadly sins there's a lot of material to
work off of they're still so they could
do something like that
I forgot that that was the thing that
was happening and you just broke my
heart
inadvertent my oh yeah it's gonna super
season three never know
Coulson Ain asks has any anime past
fifty episodes by season and I think
like Dragon Ball super gets like like
does anyone can anyone confirm but I
think a terrible super gets like
constant F asone go on adverse one
pieces have been going hot hard for like
20 years
yeah yeah like a retail which I'm really
high keep on cutting off Jojo continue I
think what it comes down to is it is
still technically supposed to be
separated in two seasons or four arcs so
I mean I don't think there has ever been
anything like above fifty episodes for
first season or an arc but I think in
terms of how its spread out yeah I mean
I'd have to look into that for sure I
don't know definitively cuz I know for
some of the longer shows they space in
by arc like Dragon Ball Z originally was
done so by different work parts of an
arc so it's really interesting I know if
there's a true definitive that goes
across the board but yeah like I said a
super was a great example that I know
for Fairy Tail was sort of the same
thing so I I know with like big one of
the most abuse in art you can keep going
yeah one piece of an arc
recently the doflamingo arc
like three years I'm not even like it
was three years like weekly it was a
fantastic art but it's a current wasn't
sure it was bring on the both my forces
you'll never hear a negative thing come
with my mouth about one piece but um
well I guess that's like me and calm you
not right but yeah I don't think we're
gonna I don't think we need to worry
about a target Titan season three having
fifty episodes but as long as it has
some episodes I'll be happy also I
killed Johnny in the chat I don't know
why you're confessing in a live stream
about killing Johnny bro but you said
that whatever Annie's father is involved
with is important and closer to the
truth and I think that's that's not even
a spoiler because we do know that Annie
talks about her father when she's
training we see a flashback early on in
season one and into manga where like her
father's telling her is training her to
be a soldier and then later he says he's
apologizing to her for something and
yeah so that's definitely an interesting
thing Annie's relationship with her
father why she's doing what she's doing
why she infiltrated the walls all that
kind of stuff so I think that will be an
interesting concept right away if you
guys like these types of streams where
we just get together and discuss to drop
a like and we might be more of them but
we do always every week due on Thursdays
Grant cafe 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time
talking about all sorts of anime stuff
so feel free to join us by the way you
know what I like most about you cyanide
what's up
it's that sexy voice of yours let's get
your own stream room okay by the way men
shout out to boondocks great row says
that I Loki look like Zeke well I've
actually heard this quite a bit so I
might start cosplaying as Zeke guys I
just need rounder glasses and growing
out my hair so stay tuned for that
trying to remember I would love to have
cyanides type of
for like my type of content I think we
could well like his by the way guys
everyone in this stream there they are
they're their own YouTube channels the
links are in the description so you can
check them all out yeah
cyanide I locked him in that cone of
Suba game a video where he introduces a
translation of that game like he was so
on point and he was very you know
excited time on that delicious English
loved it I played the game actually
cyanide I loved it glad to hear it
it's so good so uh Death Note
Riggs that was perfect
[Music]
I hacked another Death Note trailer
looks pretty good I I'm still a little
hesitant on so glad I was just gonna say
I'm like man this might have kind of
looked a little cool if you didn't have
the words Death Note at the end of the
trailer it would have looked like a cool
movie but because it says Death Note at
the end of it I can't keep making I
can't help but think like I don't
remember a [ __ ] ferris wheel in this
story it's just like random [ __ ] run
like I don't remember any of this
I'll remember ladies and oh yeah dark
Darth kylo Ren whatever
who is the blind kid from Fault in Our
Stars
I liked when I saw him I just knew blind
kid from faults in Our Stars will be
light of course all makes sense I don't
mind like how I looked I just think like
I'm still a little hesitant on light and
L like the actor is actually playing
them if they're gonna like like have to
their quirkiness or like Ella's
quirkiness and light it's like kind of
I like this meaner I don't know but I
won't really know until you see the
movie by eyes for the trailer I think
they did a decent job so far I'm excited
either way I'm excited even though it
might not be like spot-on to death no
it's gonna be a net data if they're
gonna be an adaptation right try the
Western audience yeah I kind of want it
to be a dumpster fire so that I can be
like yeah hey fun but if it's good
either way we win cuz it's like if it's
bad it's true we get to laugh at it but
if it's good we got a good death note
adaptation although we already have two
really good Death Note adaptations yeah
I like the Japanese adaptation to death
absolutely they really did the casting
well that's why I'm kind of worried I
don't think you know they're gonna be
able to match that but um
any fun fact is in the chat I guess she
has nothing better to do in her
crystallized form than to chill on
YouTube at Anime uproar shout out to
Annie and someone asked in the chat when
is a time when exactly is attack on time
season three coming out we don't know
exactly all we know is that it's
sometime in 2018 that's what they
announced on the official attack on
Titan website the Japanese website but
we don't know official release dates
sometimes you could you might not know
until like two months ahead they're like
oh by the way in two months it's gonna
start airing so it's like that with the
anime industry it's not like we know
with Game of Thrones where did it tell
you or in a year is coming out in 12
months and yeah we know with attack on
Titan always been kind of like last
minute and in the anime industry in
general it's more last minute than here
so kind of we have to be prepared for
now but as soon as we do know of course
here at anime outdoor we will let you
know we are on top of it everybody so
you guys know that summer anime 20 2017
is starting in J's and it's starting in
Friday so I'm excited for these shows
specifically for token ranbu
I'm so excited I'm hunter Jojo have you
watched the first token ranbu
no I believe I did
do you like it I did I enjoy cute boys
with swords just as much as the next
dudes apparently no well it's it's good
that you watch this you can get to the
other characters
so right now you'll know exactly what's
gonna what's going on yeah yeah uh well
I tried to get the game is is a thing -
it's like a browser game and I've tried
to get into that but it's all Japanese
and I'm like I don't know
that's a mr. anime upper I got a quick
question from you from picks mem Lord
they want to know do you think we will
get anime adaptations for attack on
Titan before the fall or Lost Girls I I
think they might incorporate that stuff
in the seasons as backstories in the
actual season like as flashbacks because
we know how much attack on Titan loves
their flashbacks but I don't think we're
gonna get spin-offs the only thing we
might get is some OVA s that deal with
that type of stuff more kind of like we
got the aamir OVA with the Titan who was
worshiping in the air which was I think
the biggest school of all the Titans in
the whole show before the second season
was that OVA with a Titan that could
actually speak and and was worshiping
Amir and then of course in the Amir
story
we got a few episodes ago we learned
what that was all about of course you
know you could speculate but we learned
for sure but yeah I think so all the A's
are possible or they might incorporate
it into those side stories they might
incorporate them into the as flashbacks
into the actual anime that's what I'm
thinking
apparently according to the chat enemy
recon is trying to sound sexy Chad he's
trying to impress any well I mean who
wouldn't I'm trying press answer also
Zeke nice abs dude nice abs the realest
question any or Mikasa the real question
damn
we're all in agreement Aaron's mom yes
and Myka saw after the time skipped for
going on say I'm not a fan of Wally's
soul
Myka after the time-skip fair enough
actually the more I think about it I'm
gonna retract my earlier stage no no
crystal and in any Krista fans over here
I I like Christmas fine but like I don't
think she's like the best or
best-looking girl in the show yeah I I
kind of the whole there's there's
certain characters in the show where I'm
like that's cool can we get back to the
other ones so any like for a lot of
Krista I was like I don't care and then
she became a story and I'm like oh well
[ __ ] me then she's actually cool now
what about a tater girl sasha is the
best and even though she's an idiot but
I like Sasha because everything she
doesn't like yeah I do that that's me I
suck okay like every time she does
anything I'm like yeah I'm potato girl
I understand yes sasha is very relatable
and I love the potato fan service and
food guard muscle in the second in the
second season that was asked I was like
so I love it because it's so much
tension right they could all die at any
time and you're like watching and then
they just give you some potato fan sir
exactly I want that to be a continuous
thing like every season is like and
here's your potatoes you're like boil em
mash them stick them in a stew ask this
question because we know Krista's real
name is historia
so should you call her his story or
should we stick with Krista that's the
thing cuz I'm biased sure so many people
are used to Krista yeah I know I have
the worst time with names like it takes
me forever to learn character names so
exactly so I'm like I'm just gonna keep
calling her Krista and I've already had
people go like its historian and I'm
like whatever original coca-cola thank
you very much that's how i know iroh
yeah so the thing with his story is that
yeah she that's her count on her true
identity Krista's her hidden identity
and so now she wants to
be free and colors of historian but yeah
I mean if you say Krista already started
we know what you mean right so it's all
yeah everyone in the chest fighting for
a knee right now
that's fine guys Nika saw after the time
skip is what I'm what I'm into thank you
very much
guys with hanji guys annie is mine okay
lay low annie is for me and if Aaron's
not gonna kiss me cus I you know there
is there are people interested so that's
cool Aaron do your thing
okay there's their people who who ship
Aaron with Christa actually actually
like now that I think about like
spoilers I'm like oh okay I can kind of
see that I can get there there is
another reason why bet that would be a
good matchup but I'm not gonna do that
for recon I I have to really watch my
tongue right now my god this thank god
nevermind I like how the guy in the chat
called armed and our Lord is like his
his profile pictures like a guy with
like tears
everywhere class that means we said my
boy has clearly proven that he is a true
psychopath now I'm like nah goo on
Armin's cool that's that's I feel like
I'm like a Yamcha defender every time I
try to help out Arman Arman is
intelligent and he's very useful but
like he should just cry less cuz I'm not
a fan of like people crying like very
quickly like you must hate boku no here
does the scene it actually there is
constantly yes Aaron having tears in his
eyes when he sees the smiling Titan you
know and the hottest thing like obvious
things are understandable but if you're
constantly crying sang up so I'm so bad
then it kind of gets old right yeah I
again I don't to say things I like that
Armin
grows into his own I guess also oh yeah
I'm like how do i how do I say this uh
he really yeah um I'm trying to think of
what I can some interesting shapes it
here
Levi X potato girl Levi a to be honest
doesn't think of anyone Levi's kind of
with hanji a little I can kind of see
that Erwin I know a lot of people
shipping with Erwin are they gay they're
all gonna die exactly get love later can
i because he got his arm cut off by a
Titan I was so oh by the way Hans ha
exactly the way his mom's mom how funny
would it be if read in the manga next
manga chapter we get like reveal that
Levi has been Loki smashing all the
chicks in the survey Corps I would have
no problem with that
good heavens like just like very low-key
he never talks about it but you know you
know I can see that thing you think yeah
haha 0 the hero he ships Levi with
cleaning equipment I I concur I have you
guys more time to roll their eyes no I
have it cuz it just looks like such pity
no no honestly please out of our quads
it's so funny it's pretty fun it's
really funny I love it like I thought it
was just kind of like the tack of things
such a serious show and then like let's
make a joke out I feel like it doesn't
work with the world I don't know do you
like means we put some memes into a show
and now it's I don't really want to
spoil what happens let's just give it a
go on a Mac and see what you think
please it's true the orphan they had the
main series is very serious and I made a
side comedy series to be less serious
and work funny and goofy but then when
they did an anime
they brought it over they released both
shows but it wasn't known so I watched
the first season then the second season
I was like what what what happened what
is going on in the show see it can be
really jarring if you don't know but it
also worked pretty well sometimes when
we are man in the Chad says arm and ex a
[ __ ] ton of books okay I think that is
probably the most accurate ship that
we've had yeah on Monica I don't think
Levi's love of knowledge we we could
have had a canonical ship in that last
episode if somebody wasn't a fuck-boy
Erin damn it well it wasn't the right
time guys I think I'm pretty sure I'm
most pleased this is I'm gonna defend
Erin's behavior even though I am the
biggest you know go for it guy don't
like [ __ ] but this was Aaron's
Thinking Myka says like you know
revealing herself to him and like how
much he cares about him and he's not
he's not like okay I'm gonna kiss her
and this Titans gonna eat us like that
would be giving up no Mika stop because
I love you and you care about me so much
I'm gonna protect you so I'm gonna go
and do something about it so it just
wasn't a right time for that he had to
fight at that moment tell her yet
after that be like no but seriously
though I wanna go grab coffee and then
like we can like make out yeah
and then look not die yeah I mean it is
it is kind of odd because they are like
brother and sister which I never had
that situation like I don't even have a
sister right so I don't know however not
knowing not being able to relate I would
definitely if I was Aaron I'd be like
listen you know very muscular abs maybe
not the most attractive thing however
you're pretty awesome so well you know
let's let's do something about it Barry
Allen and iris West on the flash grew up
in the same house they're banging I
think we should teach you better hold
some pickup lines I don't think I don't
think he is too experienced with one the
way I saw him you know just look at it
he was like my pickup lines bird eye I
can like respect Reiner
but bird I got no respect I don't like
her I don't at all like when when Annie
gets like all right in his face and she
has the crazy eyes I was like do it kill
him it's the only way
okay member Palpatine anime holic is
like Aaron X anime a poor man defending
my boy Aaron I always liked Aaron people
complain about him but man he's always
been determined he's always been
fighting against all odds like I liked
him and Aaron you know he's his head is
in the right place he's not one of those
all you soldiers are wasting our taxes
he's like he's like when someone says
that he throws a rock and trucks it at
his head he and it as a kid cuz he's
like he knows what matters so I'm a big
fan of Aaron of course Mikasa as well I
think I think Aaron must have seen
rezero
and understood that the power boost that
Subaru got from chucking REM he's like
ah ha now I understand a lot of Mikasa
hoping to get like a zenkai boosts but
it didn't work that way I mean it kinda
did yeah info on this video your
personal ship in a taco tank will come
true but you have to Josie I need reaso
season two I need reserve to burn and
Briggs is like fighting lives matter
that is an interesting actual content
that comes to the up in the next arc in
the manga for Charlie I think not for
like pains like mad at the end of his
video I found it so funny and it's like
they're just uh instinctive they have no
choice but the people I love but when
you mere tried to reason that liked it
Chris like no no the Titans are they're
not bad it's like they're killing people
that's totally bad like that'd be like
nah they'll be like if Walking Dead
with them like now we will coexist with
the Zambos it'll be fine yeah and like
that's the thing attack time reminds me
a lot of like zombie stuff obviously but
also many similarities
whereas goals and disagrees is like it's
totally different it's a totally
different genre but like to me I feel
like it's very much based on the zombie
genre like anyone could be a Titan you
just don't know right like anyone could
turn into a zombie like right so yeah
speaking of goes and couldn't he make it
to the stream today no he's busy working
on another attack on Titan video and we
also have another project that we're
hoping to drop non attack on that
project that we're talking will be the
drop in tomorrow or the next day so
we're very busy so that Holliman just
call them into your room well actually
I'm gonna go to the washroom right now
but I will leave it to you guys to keep
chatting while I do that goodbye awkward
silence awkward silence peace so guys um
how many of you think that goes in is
actually the real star the enemy of her
Network I mean right now putting the
team on his back
no adamak would like did a lot of like
yeah for a while goes in with in school
and go with advanced school and he's
been putting on this attack on Titan
videos I just took off the channel like
huge ya know um they got some great
teamwork weight collaboration as well
they work really well so they've
completely earned a lot of that gotten
here every some of it so I was like oh
yeah I'm catching up and then boom later
gotta get my brother to help me with
videos that's actually Oh nobody I don't
believe there are enemy any code geass
videos coming up soon there's been no
news but if there is I could tell you
anime uproar will be the person to
deliver it so history
we could talk about how great undead
wolf Emilia is we could talk about it we
could that is a fact that is a fact okay
I would like to ask like recon and Road
Roke I know I should probably sign that
as well you guys have been looking at
the like summer anime list chart type of
thing what do you guys recommend I was
watching JoJo's livestream if I want to
watch like like 10 minutes I can
recommend it yeah
Jojo what's up with the skeleton that is
a hater that I tracked down okay that's
what happens first of all what genre do
you like the most
um I I spread across go north um she
fast Shonen of course I like like
martial arts like historical first one
I'm definitely gonna wring I recommend
for you is token ranbu for sure because
that has it's about samurai it's gonna
be about martial arts for sure action
fantasy drama that's the first one I
recommend for you okay do I need to
watch the previous season that yeah
they're talking about or no the previous
season was just about you know getting
to know the characters but this one is
completely new so you don't have to it's
from you photo Bowl yeah so that's the
du-du-duh
faith in a unlimited bridge yeah yeah I
recommend is of course Issyk I was
smartphone which is gonna be another
transported to another world serious so
I'm excited for that the back sky god
damn he's got a ship I'm sorry to have
enough of stuck in another world but if
I die I'll go to another world that'll
be my life goddammit hopefully about
kono subbu the world I would prefer that
because it's like well at least I get to
like hang out with like darkness and
aqua and mega mean this is hanging with
Kozma though I don't really want to hang
out with customer doesn't seem too good
a solo yeah he seems like he's funny on
screen but to put up with Kozma would
problem
okay well my entire scream just froze
there first I can push it yeah I know a
mile away we get it but I think I think
we're still good at sunako-sama it just
made Joe Joe freeze up there completely
almost killed the stream oh sorry I
definitely hear you guys all turn world
anime fantasy world transportation anime
I feel like one thing why attack sign is
so interesting it's like that is a world
nobody wants to be transported to right
because a lot of times we'll have
questions like what kind of anime world
would you like to live in and no one
ever says attack on Titan right so that
isn't something that makes ready by the
way are you guys ready to watch Levi
play soccer
it's called cap Bucky kept Bucky Danny
she I don't know how to pray but that
one is the main character is so similar
to leave I'm localized it'll be about
soccer
I'm a huge soccer fan because of course
I live in the UK and here it's all about
football and I support Liverpool it's my
time I am such a soccer fan that I don't
call it soccer called football like
everyone else doesn't matter yeah your
football and your American football yeah
Megan but football for the win
yes football then you have lemon balls
well yeah guys so I think I think we've
confirmed that I need to grow my hair so
I can cosplay as Zeke however I really
need to get those ABS so there you go
cosplay goals
everyone cosplay goals I need to get
some need to get ripped for next anime
North I need to get ripped I want that
footage of us doing archery really bad
thank you oh let's see what that looks
like
I don't know role-playing right well I
thought uh Mac like Mackel not was gonna
upload it but I guess not well he's been
like mi a he is
banned stuff yes like work stuff but he
has crossed the 2000 mark so we
hopefully in cosplaying as REM soon
that is a thing I have to finish Ruiz
ero when we read when the channel
reaches 1500 and I am the only person on
the planet who doesn't like that show so
that's really hard for me Reesie ro yeah
I'm not the biggest freezer okay
I don't like us but I do have a
reputation for hating it apparently no
like I have come completely agree I have
a lot of reservations about re0 as a
show I thought that like duh
pacing was odd its themes don't like the
atmosphere doesn't add up it goes from
me a comedy to like a weird horror you
start with others law issues you're
gonna start another war yeah this is why
I don't like talking like I want to talk
about resume but I'm always like trash
about it because you might start a war
with a lot of people especially me wait
on the handle it breaks already in the
chat talking smack about real football
and [ __ ] real football bro like I don't
like people who dive either but football
is fun America the wall you're just
falling all over the place I don't
understand it I try to watch it I can
get it but I mean I understand that
people like it I personally also
wouldn't play it because I don't to get
a concussion and [ __ ] but you know to
each his own to each his own I prefer to
watch American football like I love
watching it like every Sunday definitely
but um so I say I went to like to
Toronto FC games and last week or
whatever and like it's like watching
people die of cheeses me so much like
you barely got touched and they're like
rolling driving their ankle than like
[ __ ] off like a handle this I'm started
me off so much to get the last team was
amazing with actually the championship
but um that all because no yeah diving
does suck and that's why I hate you know
iron Robin or whatever his name is I in
Robin yeah yeah the next guy like he is
the biggest biggest [ __ ] when it comes
to diving like oh my god
like he overall he's a good player on
you know the greats
but his diving I just want to smack him
like ah anyways but have you watched
days have you watch the football anime
called days I have haven't who do not
watch it adamak you will hate it the
protagonist what do you mean you'll hate
him oh yeah I know I know adamak now
okay the crab it yes I ate it off
because he told me it's fried
I agree you might hate the main
character because he started he's kind
of a Shinji Ikari
no he's completely he's a weak bastards
they're gonna really hate him he look
like a strong manly man by the way Parma
Roy says imagine if Titans played
football now I would want to see that
either either type of football I would
want to see that [ __ ] I would want to
hear what about honey comment they kind
of did play American football when they
were ganging up on Reiner in the final
two episodes yes when he was trying to
like you know throw them at Aaron and
said like and that looked like American
football like tackling rugby type of
stuff it was funny now I want to say
yeah the real tackle is when adding
control that tightened to completely
jump on that smiling Titan that was a
real tackle yeah that was those nuts and
all the people who are like obviously if
you watched are smiling in time to video
all of you were like yes finally got the
smiling Titan not so fast not so fast
guys this one time you listen as you
know as black and white as you think but
yeah coming out to this stream I think
we can start wrapping it up soon however
very excited for attack on Titan season
3 August see here on this channel you
can get all the latest videos all the
latest news so stay tuned drop a like if
you want a attack a Titan we do come out
soon maybe it'll affect the outcome
probably not but who knows we're crazy
and I look alike my guests were here on
the stream everybody in the chat
obviously including those people who
keep just like swearing
like maniacs like I don't know what it
is but this stream they don't usually
get just like a bunch of people just
swearing and [ __ ] but we had it this
week but yeah
cyanide blizzard let's start with you
tell us who you are and what you do and
kind of like other personal things about
your life like your address my hip aside
I Blizzard i do first impressions
basically it's like a reaction except
it's more comedic I have fun at the show
not making fun of it but rather having
fun with it um currently on hiatus
because I'm a bit busy but I'm hoping
eventually to get back into that at some
point got a few other projects few other
irons in the fire so we'll see where we
go from there but you can mainly catch
me on rad cafe and Indiana may uproar
discord as well link I do believe is it
a description yep guys if you like
discord and chatting with us on a daily
basis about an anime I think arts bird
we have we are pleased to have table
[ __ ] in there Briggs once in a while so
yeah definitely a fun time and I spent
entirely too much time there but I love
it a lot of my people people I saw on
boo and shot those in here in Amelia and
a bunch of other peeps Ellen creep Ellen
anime dude everyone into discord our
moderators and admins and everybody
loved you guys this core doesn't work
for me for some reason Anna Mac because
you need to reinstall it probably it's
probably very simple all right I love
you shut down elfs you changed your name
man what the hell your real name is elf
don't do them give me that stuff don't
give me that stuff elf shout out to elf
he's also an important member of our
team on this court I'm going to you Joe
Joe who are you and what do you do
my name is Joe Joe I kind of do a show
called in a minute sometimes and I've
been kind of branching out doing more
review kind of stuff and I don't really
know what I do but I talk a lot that's
kind of my thing
that's what I do but my channels kind of
going through a weird phase where I
don't know what I make anymore
so that's fun yeah I have a project
coming out yeah I have a project coming
out July 3rd and it's gonna be running
through the entire month so that should
be exciting looking forward to seeing
that thank you
you know Joe Joe Joe thank you bro cars
are having you back on the show here and
we'll have you back again soon and his
link is in the description now going to
Briggs from all day Anna Mae hello hi I
am Briggs from all day Anna Mae I make
FAQ videos like interesting things you
wouldn't already know about characters
and series the anime animal style I also
like to explain concepts about anime
like one for all from my hero academia
he transferable to work and that's cool
stuff like that you know come check me
out if you like
absolutely link in the description and
last but not least and I'm a recon to
you hey guys how's it going
you doing alright yeah I see you right
there anyways I do daily live reactions
and I'm gonna be doing it all for a
summer anime 2017 hopefully give me you
all my first impressions and if I
recommend the show's to you or not and I
also do a top 10 anime lists for to
recommend shows that new shows or old
shows that you guys were might want to
watch or if you already have watched
them but yeah that's what I do and of
course hopefully my voice sounded sexy
at the start and yeah
Rikka hashtag recon no pico hashtag
havoc no pico and yeah [ __ ] that and I
love you all yes that's all I gotta say
yes I love you all thanks recon for
joining us again recons link is in the
description as well London is his City
ah I don't live in London whatever who
cares who cares man it's every day bro
who cares that my voice really matches
my profile pic but I feel like I feel
like
recon you're gonna end up making that
ASMR video I just I just I just know
about that good with that type of [ __ ]
I'm a mod expert any of anyways yeah but
you got any fans my other fans probably
think I'm such a weirdo
I don't thank you oh yeah it's not
London is my city that would have made
sense it's England is my city so there
you go exactly
yeah thanks to Tolson for clean ground i
I think to logically so I forgot it was
actually in the news month I was gonna
say and now we are the ones who are the
fools Afric such a great time on YouTube
guys YouTube truly is a great pin a
great place great place you can love and
you can but most of us just do both at
the same time
well yeah thanks again everyone in the
traffic join us every week we're here
Thursday 5:00 p.m. eastern standard time
talking anime with a bunch of cool
people thank you to Jojo breaks from all
the anime anime recon and cyanide
blizzard and until next time see us bass
cowboys